[Music]
it was definitely a special moment last
week a source told ET that justin
timberlake is close to finalizing a deal
to take center stage at the 2018 Super
Bowl and fans are hoping and if it
happens in sync
joins call it a coincidence that Lance
Bass told ET a months ago he was up for
the challenge did you guys ever do that
again
yes of course
maybe next year February should he give
us a call in itself
we're in still medley of all like the
best performances the past
2018 also marks the band's 20 year
anniversary it's almost 20 years since
the first NSYNC album came out 1998 here
right are we doing something special I
think so
alright I mean I'll go ahead and bounce
it right now they are we are coming out
with a really cool vinyl edition of our
Christmas album new music no no no it's
a strict re-release of the Christmas
album on vinyl cuz people didn't really
want it confining and I think it's
really cool in that shop it'll come out
for this Christmas have you guys talked
like idea of a group change yeah we do
we talk daily yeah all five of you I
would have to shoot you if you saw the
stuff we wrote to each other oh well
fine you know pictures on Instagram of
us from the 90s and yeah so we're always
giving it to each other
mainly Joey Joey gets a lot of the brunt
of our jokes yeah so yeah it's fun I
mean those guys are my brothers
and so we act like immature brothers all
the time the guys are still clearly
close but the NFL is keeping quiet
telling et quote we are not going to
speculate on particular artists